but
if we look at the real worst case uh
analysis here
is one day you're pretty young now
but that's not gonna last very long
you're gonna die one day is that
something you think about
a little bit are you afraid of death
well i'm up the mindset
of let's make that a productivity hack
i'm in the mindset of um
we need to confront that soon yeah so
let's do what we can
now so that when we really confront and
think about it we're more likely to
feel better about it so in other words
like let's let's focus now on
living and doing things in such a way
that we're proud of
so that when it really comes time to
confront that we're more likely to say
like okay
i feel kind of good about the situation
so what uh when you're laying on your
deathbed
would you in looking back what would
make you think like i
did uh i do okay i'm proud of that i
optimized
the hell out of that that's a good i
mean it's a good question that the the
go
backwards on i mean this this is like
david brooks's
uh eulogy virtues versus resume virtues
right so his argument is that uh that's
another interesting dc area person i
keep thinking of interesting tcr
people all right david brooks is here
too yeah um
you he his argument he thinks eulogy
virtues is so what we eulogize is
different than what we
promote on the resume uh that's his
whole thing now right his second
mountain
wrote the character about these books or
he has this whole premise of there's
like this professional phase and there's
a phase of
uh giving of yourself and sacrificing on
behalf of other people
i don't know maybe it's all mixed
together right you wanna i think living
by a code is important right i mean uh
there's something that's not emphasized
enough i always think of advice that
my undergrad should be given that that
they're not given especially at a place
like georgetown that has this like deep
history of you know trying to promote
human flourishing because of the jesuit
connection
uh there's such there's such uh
resiliency and pride that comes out of
living well even when it's hard like
living according to a code living accord
to
which which you know i think religion
used to structure this for people
and but in its absence you need some
sort of replacement but this uh even
when things were soldiers get this a lot
right
the experience is a lot even when things
were tough i was able to persist in
living this way that i knew was right
even though it wasn't the easiest thing
to do in the moment like fewer things
give humans
more resiliency like having done that
your relationships are strong right many
people coming to your funeral as a
standard like a lot of people are gonna
come to your funeral like i mean you
matter to a lot of people
and then maybe having done to to the
extent of whatever
capabilities you are happen to be
granted you know and they're different
for different people and
some people can sprint real fast and
some people can do math problems uh
try to actually do something of impact
i'll just uh promise to give gift cards
to anybody who shows up to the funeral
you're gonna hack it i'm gonna hack even
the funeral there's gonna be a
lottery wheel you spin when you come in
and someone goes away with ten thousand
dollars
you